happy Monday Brendon what so I wanted to
thank the people in of Austin mmm bombed
out in versal awesome dude Boston Austin
Texas don't say no it was raining it was
I celebrating the New England Patriots
win no no dude no bro I'm talking about
Austin Austin yeah now Austin home of
Justine's my boy mark we had a good time
I love it there
Jeff cities oh I love Justin the best at
the French yes my places I ate there
every night ate steak I like steak down
there it's dark
oh it's so [ __ ] good I feel like I'm
the vampire New Orleans I know me too
red walls subversive subversive and
coziest fully come on up guys
my friends place does to a man if you're
straight and you step into a French
place you wanna be barking weird by
weird way keep it weird just don't don't
just don't label me anything bro so I
don't want to do what I want to do rah
don't put me into a corner your song he
sucked the boys off do what I want to do
when I'm in Austin sometimes a nossa I
want eat some assless chaps and go wild
that's right Austin does have a lot of
that you you you'll be in there and your
waiter might be you know might be
somebody who is gender very gender
nonspecific and it's all good it's all
good
that's why everyone I see I say what's
up cowboy our cow person nope hey hope
everyone Madeline what's up cowboy
really they like it uh-huh uh-huh I say
hello cow per non-binary gender specific
Pirlo cow yes Cassie hello human cow
human cal human hi can you give me a
time though yeah you could live out
there huh I sure could live out there I
sure could now not in the summer I don't
know if you know about the summer but
it's about a thousand degrees either me
man well I feel I can't do Vegas in the
summer
miserable Vegas isn't too bad but I want
you to take Vegas heat and then I want a
dress I want you to get I want you to
add biggest misery if another percent
well I've been there Ben Houston the
summer did stamp and use the summer yeah
it's hot
locusts I'm not too worried though
because
I'm indoors you see war indoors but very
rarely hanging that heat is like a big
ol wet blanket on you now I do well in
in wet heat meters my my skin doesn't my
hair gets curly might not break out my
ass gets super sweaty but yep I could
live in Texas there's one place so you
live outside California Texas I would
agree with you 100%
I'd like more outreach in there I like
the people of Texas I Reno why I like it
it's so vast and wide I don't have to
see people here's the other reason I
like it I could have tigers and lions I
think there are more lions and tigers in
Texas then I'll take a look place in the
world this is cool though and there's no
state tax
now listen man it's America America
awesome has that like Austin has also
moved in a little bit well yeah that's
true but awesome the phase where you'll
see a hipster with a [ __ ] nose ring
but he's also packing a piece yeah it's
like oh we're liberal but we believe in
guns as well yeah no liberal but we're
still yeah but this cell tax is still my
property seized step over um I may have
tattoos on my neck and and I'm wearing
Birkenstocks but I fully feel a legit
shows at cap city are the best the best
buy that outfit there I did buy this
shirt there i I've said you know that
the shirt you know mad right nice I was
like maybe I'll just get a little crazy
to get it of course stag a bad guy
provisions backed out here I know who's
stags I'm by the way any so I go there
and I go I want to go here because this
is a store it's an individual store the
guy goes I buy a bunch of stuff he goes
he recognizes and he good bro than there
ever bro I'm celebrity and he goes from
celebrity and he goes do you go to one
on a bikini I was like I'll [ __ ] I
forgot about that those not dory yeah
well instead of packing at all I could
have gotten a bikini but you pull you
pulled a little Wayne you something
about traveling you want you want to
spend money when I yeah I'm like you
know what sure have a great outfit that
I packed from home yeah I want to wear
something new tonight I feel better
about it doesn't feel like doesn't feel
like money somehow it feels like play
money or something yeah that's very
strange feel like you're on vacation
just won't look fly for your show
correct so you wore that for your show
almost got almost almost decided there
in Austin I'll do some dumb [ __ ] like I
walked by a store with like huge belt
buckles and
cowboy boots and hats and I'll get it as
well you know I mean I'm like I mean
there's no rule that says I can't walk
around with a big buckle some a pair of
Lucchese I'm tempted monster skin boots
and a [ __ ] hat no one's gonna look
double to have a hat in the belt buckle
why can't Brian the kid count at 50 to
turn a new leaf and become a cowboy you
know I'm saying could get a plan yeah
some land working the work in the land
for you I met a young lady there who is
at the show and talking to her and a
bunch of people I said what did you do
she goes well I grew up on a cattle farm
I was like what she goes oh yeah I'm a
cattle I mean I Drive cattle oh I bet
she could melt your dick better than
anybody in that state bro
can you not can you not I was about to
say that she competed in barrel racing
and you had to say cuz I said California
she was she drove steer and you said I
bet she could milk your know you can't
even say it out loud you got a Monday
that didn't cost you money didn't cross
your mind sure did just squeezing those
utters I well guess what when a girl
works my dog I don't I don't get on all
fours and have her milk my dog no hey hi
unless she's gonna eat unless she's
gonna unless she's gonna work my my
bunny hole just milk it on all fours and
you just milk my dog yeah you know I may
have done that once in my life funny
friend you have a friend yeah we do we
know this guy when he went in for a
massage and we meet and we we got legit
massage you he thought he was doing the
same go go in his room he's on all fours
getting milk like a cow but this huge
headache Korean ladies just to it I am
like sorry I know I had it with milk and
all they know given the dick
old Indian rug brands like no only 7,000
podcasts shuttle to Austin though
shuttle they give to [ __ ] Indian rug
burns yeah listen how awesome is the
spot oh man did you watch Super Bowl
I watched the Super Bowl not surprised
that Pat's found a way to get done very
nice with Ames defense stop you
yeah you watch the Superbowl I did we're
at my place by yourself actually at my
sister's place what am I saying
I was my sister oh wait everything yeah
your place are your sisters my sisters I
did watch it you did i watch the whole
thing it was Carrie boring I'm very
impressed with with the Rams defense but
again if the Rams offense couldn't get
it done
couldn't gang off enjoy you you belch
and find a way he's a mastermind you
want oh you guys think McVeigh's the new
you think he's the answer the the God's
gift to football and very cobby knows
for a hot second seeing it before gonna
shut it down that's right that's what
that's right and I'm gonna find some
more such a boring game though even
after like Britt was scoring game and
super brady was like yeah it was a very
weird way to win because they'd already
won like you you knew once he missed
that that field goal and also covers all
the four myths left they word right like
that's about the - you knew they're just
gonna melt the clock Brady and Gronk and
even the coach like cool man six one
right now and I like one that she was
like - you do you see yourself I mean
are you have you done it do you he goes
on now man I don't want to keep doing
this I want to see Brady plants at least
45 and I think he could because he's not
gotten injured and he told them - I love
this heals I'm gonna stop playing when I
suck right now I'm pretty damn good he's
I bet when I suck you're the best
100% best of all time and balichek is of
course the great genius of all now now
so we've we've we've recapped the game
doesn't matter by seeing games bold I'd
like to do is talk a little bit about my
assessment now I think maroon 5 or
anybody who performed at halftime is
getting a lot of [ __ ] I think it's
unfair this is a matter of size football
you're allowed to perform I don't think
it means you're into they all these all
these people like it doesn't mean you're
into policeman says it's none of that
you know they didn't get paid for it
right you know they took the money other
good
pay them the 500 grand oh yeah so shut
the [ __ ] up everybody
now plus how many black people were part
of that performance yeah a lot at all it
said this America big boy from Super
Bowl and football is America and it's a
time when everybody comes together
American it's time people come together
so so just because you perform at
halftime doesn't mean they shot the
blower your virtue don't support that
they don't hire Colin Kaepernick it's
all that [ __ ] all right
so what's on dude but you can't take
your shirt off now
I know you have probably different point
of view on I love that I'm living yeah I
know you know I think here's some sugar
in this tank though well we're gonna
talk about that too
I'm gonna talk about that too this is
Kim's I grew up in Brentwood by the way
I believe wealthy kid it's all good
talented I think he's talented I like
his voice I like I like the way he looks
I thought his girl would be hotter don't
know his girl I want to see her I want
to see his girl but here's the thing I'm
saying again when he took when he when
he had the tank top on allow Ford the
chills pretty cool enjoy a little short
little short little short little short
me believe this I'm cool yeah gangster
yeah this yeah
I'll suck your dick well I don't mind
about that is it's a little low that's
it that's a choker yes bro
no okay and that's probably true too I
even forgive the shortness you got the
tank top I went oh all right you got
your sleeves you're working your arms I
like it am i mad I'm gonna give you a
pass he's like - Travis like Jordans all
that I don't mind that and I don't mind
if you're gonna be on if you're if
you're a rock star and you have a tank
top on I'm gonna let you go and just lay
on the middle of winter and you take a
shirt off no it's a little bit like when
we were at a gym you and I and a guy was
working out with a shirt off had a very
good body but I remember he looked at me
and I go he's got a great body you're
working out like that and a bunch of
other guys were here a lot of athletes
and you said something to the effect of
mmm you can't do that I don't do it you
can't do it now you take your shirt off
here's my problem it's bro code hey Adam
you got a great body
congratulations on shaving your torso
getting all those fantastic tattoos you
couldn't be more ankle fornia and all
that
[ __ ] you made it a little bit about
yourself
you're trying to be too sexy you could
have left it alone I was very happy with
your sexy with the tank top now he was
voted he's most sexy of course two years
ago of course he was people's magazine
most sexiest man I'm sure then you take
your shirt off now this is the Super
Bowl bodied up though he's bodied up
nice too and my sister and her friend we
like leave him alone leave him alone I
went I I understand you want my girl
some reason you get what you should get
more tattoos Oh sir
he looks good that's all there you go
then and that's but again a lot of
decoration the reason you can't take
your shirt off is because you look that
good there's actually there's actually
that reason let us like it renewed
tonight gripper though we're dudes bro
hey bro I there are a lot of guys they
could they have good bodies like that
not Allah but I mean they're people that
can do this you're making it about
yourself now it's already a little bit
controversial just sing the song other
bands like right the rest bands like
what do you take your shirt I'm moving
around for we get it you're gonna take
SATs and got Leon he got greedy he got a
little greedy
you got your tank top on I'm happy I
give you a pass by to iron and chains on
hang around his neck at least now you
take your shirt now you get in greedy
now you're trying to turn all the girls
on and you're being deliberate about it
and you made a little cell and the guys
though because some of those moves on it
oh okay sure that's not how most folk
move when they're into the women what
all of his moves on it I have zero
problem with it actually celebrated yeah
chicken you think now now I'm not so
good shirt often all right well that's
okay yeah fine little twink here and
then some oh no well he's probably
taking a lot of dance classes cuz he was
probably a showbiz kid sure come on yeah
I hear so you take a lot of dance those
moves weren't dance well those those
moves were I'm again flare they're flare
let me show you my feathers this isn't
enough for me
I got bling around my neck I got tattoos
everywhere it's not enough now I got to
move my hippie hips you know what you're
onto something here it's not enough that
every woman wants to suck me off I'm
trying to do thank you
three Crossville now you cross the line
because you're getting greedy with all
the genders some for the rest you gettin
greedy with all the genders and I'm
telling you right now
true or false as talented as he is good
stuff I can't hang out with a guy like
that that's not a dude I ever hang out
with not not hanging out at the judge
bro I'm judging him maybe wearing out to
be friends nope nope he looks a little
bit like a tool mmm and he's talented
and I like him and I think he's got a
good voice love the band - bit of a bit
of a tool I thought I thought the whole
Super Bowl like Travis Scott was not
good the guy who came out now that's a
nice smile this Tally's man yeah what
was that thing around this [ __ ] waist
Louis Vuitton belt of some sort terrible
terrible terrible belt his Jordans are
dope then I'll probably buy him yeah
yeah yeah he could have left himself
alone though without that ridiculous
Bell whole there's a whole lot of felons
of the crowd in the crew so you know a
lot of things happen this weekend you
know Afeni I'm Levine has sugar in his
tank basically saw Batman is on peds
when I saw Joe Rogan post a picture of a
Tesla and sent me a picture went bro
bought a Tesla
yeah cause I'm a picture of a person
like this nope you did he called me up
because I'm I'm converted bro I go what
do you mean he got the hundred D it's
got some ludicrous beggars it's so quiet
and fascicle yeah I know now though that
he's got that hundred D I I go oh I kind
of want to get one I'm getting 75 D I
know and I was like maybe I'll get the
Naugle and here's the best part
we're dealing he and I have different
cash flow I do well but I go how much it
cost and he goes he doesn't know hey
guys I don't know he doesn't know that's
when he got cash when you go I don't
know
yeah but either way I can't get into the
test limit I just can't live in the
hundred D I've driven them yeah it's
just you drove the fast fast drive in a
man it's just not for me I don't you
like your I understand and I understand
it's just got this you need petrol I
don't know it just doesn't do anything
for me
maybe if I Drive the Porsche one that's
coming out the electric Porsche one cuz
they make a better car it just doesn't
it doesn't excite me I don't hate
cool you like you might get why people
like but I feel like your car if you
like your car and now all cars now that
have that that engine sound it's
actually computer-generated right yeah I
think your engine is [ __ ] I think
your engines quiet looks for the test
like you know your engines bullshitting
do listen to I'm sorry to do this you
might as well be talking to me about the
Chinese government they've no money
about that as you've been the fake
engine noise or ink on speaker and so
you're letting the forces not you and
you're like man but it's [ __ ] dude
you have to suck a gaff to get the Tesla
how's that work like we going to use go
hey here's my man card I might as well
be driving a tampon down there dude all
I'm gonna say is if you and Rogan are
gonna race
please take with your portion that silly
fin please do me a favor
please take take a step back take a step
back get yourself a warm glass of milk
and drink that down and then take
yourself a nap cuz you're not in the
same league as the Ludacris Bacchus he
laughs at you so again he want you to
give me a favorite thing getting lower
class because I'm sound goes I live my
life 1/4 mile and gives me a hundred
grand to race um yeah I'm not racing
anybody I'm too old for that but his car
is a drink don't care mind wake learn
all yours you've got a big ol fin oh you
know you should do an airport no here's
what each car after you guys get done
sucking the boys off that Tesla line up
you're too stupid toy cars that are not
calling up your iPad's with for my
[ __ ] toy line up your iPads and I'm
gonna get in my new [ __ ] Raptor and
go cute cute cute right the [ __ ] you do
that wouldn't make a [ __ ] ding on my
car oh how my truck is wouldn't make a
dent in dink would he made a dent
Oh our iPads and then yeah I take you
the stupid chaos not gonna fix it don't
call it an iPad man you try put out my
face so you got a raptor yeah I did
Brian it's got some horsepower on it
yeah about six hundred man this thing's
tuned to the Gil you trick it out sure
did who makes the Raptor four or does
ever heard of
American man so you got an American
truck yeah bro the baddest trick yeah
you're gonna just run us over
yep bring your stupid electric iPad I'm
gonna run it over you and Rogan what's
the sound again deke dude you hear this
yeah bro so when you want to ride in my
vehicle it ain't happening come on dude
you're wasting gas don't do that don't
be such a [ __ ] gas cover
oh here's the other you're like a bully
of the road do you want to drive San
Francisco yeah oh cool
charge your car four times on the way
well they have spots I can wait
miserable I had to I had to go to super
charger there was a there was a line I
had to wait until people were done - you
know what Tesla is these days in LA it's
it's kind of the new if just standard
911 like agents get them those
dick-sucking agents you know cuz they
think they're cool they don't know cars
so like Tesla's chicks dig Tesla's and
they get that yeah that's what Tesla's
no no but not mine I have I got midnight
midnight black tunic I think it's called
midnight 17 cool I did dink my cars dink
hey tink tink
that you're doing it like an
afterthought you just ruined my car you
don't give a [ __ ] huh
oh just gonna be more upset dude so so
you got the Raptor I know I'm telling
you I know you tricked it out what would
what would attract like you trick it out
with well it came tricked out first of
all with carbon-fiber hood complete lift
package suspension the suspension so
major and because I haven't get a
4-wheel it sure aren't I'm gonna
four-wheel this is sure ain't by for one
I mean go over the tracks at the mall
yeah exactly the suspension so big or
cut out the bed and because this shock
stick out of the bed
oh that's important yeah that's
important extra five grand for that
obviously I don't know hey I don't know
[ __ ] be Rogen how do you know bro
don't try to be Rogen I don't ask me how
much that cost
dinner hey man making me mad today dude
you got to making me mad dude I box I
keep boxing gloves in the back of my
Tesla did you lose all credibility on
the street you drive Tesla nah man
that thing I gotta just charge it it's
like talking about cars now I'm gonna do
this to you and Rogan that's a question
any car
I do you think I should man nope
you're out dude both you guys that's all
I knew super ass we've got good deal you
guys are out man you're being super me
yeah I'm mad bro being a villain us I
feel like both my friends transitioned
if I feel like Rogan was the last to go
lasted the true Elastigirl in that dude
had a barracuda had a kobe a Shelby
Cobra Shelby Cobra we're never gonna see
he had all those clothes Hawk got
support like you I feel like yes
transition man it's heartbreaking
do you know what I feel like I'm an
episode I am jazz with Rogan abroad you
know what I had a weird feeling like
I've never done this to Rogan but as he
was Tommy he got his new Tesla like you
really liked it oh no no I had this
really weird impulse to go hey we've
been friends a long time and he I know
you love me and he could yeah and I go
but like a long time longer than anybody
else you know he'd be like yeah I go can
I release your tension can i no no no
that's not what I was gonna say happen
in a movie I just documentary I just
watch I want to see it away
whoa um I wanted to ask him I wanted to
ask him literally I had this impulse and
I stopped myself to go can I have your
icon I know I wanted him to be like yeah
and just give it to me but that with the
Bronco yeah I like that I feel like he
said used to have a Bronco yeah but it
was $25,000 it wasn't yeah and yeah
there wasn't dude how much you're paying
for your stupid iPad wait tell me about
we Bronco tell me about release dude I
went so hard in the paint I'm below the
belt and I gave people splurt splurt
again I can't stop talking around all
that assessments and I give the whole
narrow down below a belt people gonna be
pissed
here here's all you need to know it's
called a ducted in plain sight this dude
scares me starts molesting this girl
this little girl yup says he's a
pedophile and then he infiltrates the
whole family starts [ __ ] the mom as
well as months in the sister and would
stay the night in the daughter's room
how was the daughter young like you know
12th or 13
so then the end of the parents go okay
whatever they're weird so he starts
[ __ ] the mom right then so he doesn't
get in trouble so they can't presence or
mom know that he's no they they said
they didn't but they definitely did a
grown man stands on your daughter's bed
here's the other thing so then they show
the dad talking fat out of shape hands
on stomach like this talking about the
daughter and the mom how unbelievable
what they did I think is yeah then they
picked me up from work he's you know
he's one of our close friends going on
vacation with him we're driving he
starts talking about how his
relationships not going well with his
wife and how he no enjoy sex and he
looks over at me goes I need help man
can you help release the tension and I
started laughing like this is classic
and he goes so I did the worst thing in
my life I've reached over and I gave him
a [ __ ] white a dude yeah bro what a
weird world this guy was just it's the
guy off my television I've ever seen
what's it called abduct done complaints
in plain sight and I don't want give any
more of the premises that sounds like
off you know that's gonna be a movie in
no time yeah I think they sold the
rights but when he's what age hey this
was no show these to this is the 70s to
do oh I came and released him of tential
in my hand yeah you [ __ ] him bro yeah
you and so yes for sure and guess what
the reason why he did that he's such a
sociopath because they're they're in the
church latter-day saints he knew that
the more around ran upon so he was cool
you're gonna rat on me about molesting
your daughter I'm gonna tell the entire
city our entire neighborhood that you're
homosexual in your Al's oh man oh man oh
yeah hey what's up guys back what's
going on nothing much just came from
Best Buy House Best Buy thanks Kat
that's wise you're still killing it huh
I don't know it looks kind of sad does
it yeah geek squad yeah you see the geek
squad boys well oh then that when I was
bought a TV they were like now which
cable do you want HDMI we've got a 1/4
percent cotton copper there this is the
2 percent copper that'll be $85 they're
going get get the [ __ ] out of here with
your terrible marketing give me the
[ __ ] cable I want the cheapest one no
you what the shot I didn't
fiber optic one for the best some
[ __ ] what is this mr. got the right
who rocked it Jax do stuff did you play
this little guy I want to see the guy
are you talking about mr. B yeah I want
to see the real story but wait is that
the daughter to what it was that's the
as mr. B writes mr. B right there
that's really gross this he's seen this
cat I've heard about it I have seen the
documenting daughter that's the kid I
would cut that dude's head off with a
knife play that trailer chin people like
that or there's some evil [ __ ] Bieber
and B and C can we talk about this by
time I hear this one but I just I it was
I what you know me I'm balls deep in
doctor I nothing makes me happier than a
documentary and Ike the judge feel that
don't watch him cuz I feel like I'm
smarter after I watch a documentary yeah
and this one you know me i watch all
documentary yeah even bad ones dude this
is the craziest [ __ ] I've ever stood the
guy ever get caught did he ever
I don't wanna split it alright if he
listened blow a bit I spelled it for
everyone I gotta see this don't tell me
because I want to watch it but I do want
to control that mr. Virgil had such an
effervescent wonderful personality we
became very good friends
he was so engaged with the kids - I mean
he really was fun and he could give me a
great feeling about myself I was
attracted to him Oh Jan Roberge and
Robert were stalled at an unnatural
relationship I loved him as deeply as
I've ever loved anyone when she didn't
come home I was a little nervous it was
a nationwide search dan went with me
voluntarily they bring in alien and mind
washing never be anybody from me but can
well unfortunately people like that need
a bullet to the head doesn't do it
justice bro I got to see it now says the
dad jacked that guy off well the guy the
dad looks like a very weak oh he's such
a [ __ ] coward
you watch it and you do that parent no
the parents should be in prison yeah but
they're just they're just weak dum-dums
no no listen the sound done they are
homeboy right steals the daughter comes
back those listen I went off therapists
in California they said because I was
younger well don't tell me don't tell me
I got to see this now I gotta see it I'm
all I need you know is that guy on the
right Jax the abductor of that's
incredible
can you release some tension this is my
dog just do just that guy's probably gay
by the way there's a family yes right I
mean come on and by the way like you
said hmm Did you touch it or did you use
your ma do in the 70s hand jobs yeah no
that's like giving so a kiss on the
cheek is but your mouth and I want you
to go and pray about it and back dude
they [ __ ] in the 70s and didn't exist
well in the 70s it was post pill
pre-aids so there was there was a crazy
amount of casual sex but she grew up to
be a beautiful young lady
yes she's gorgeous but you know you hit
[ __ ] no but she's very attractive
i'ma have something I have a direct line
to her all right if you're interested
yeah we'll talk all right we'll talk
thank you for bringing that attention to
that dude you gotta watch yourself how
well have you broken down the fights
that are coming up this weekend yeah bro
I do a show for Showtime all right this
weekend is Anderson so I have a chance I
think is a chance no chance that people
think why Sampson Silva yeah I mean he's
guaranteed at I'll shot his style Benner
gonna respect them too much and not
unleash the fury like you can on him
yeah which I don't think he stopped ever
sobbing her lights them up like a
goddamn Brazilian Christmas tree right
what style blender a high-level I love
uh kick box before that okay tons of
fights tennis fans yeah yeah but again
no one really moves like him so but the
other thing is you know Anderson Silva
makes him special he's a world-class
boxers well like iam box the box
Maroni's trying to compete against Roy
Jones like his boxing is phenomenal yes
that could be you know I think it's
better for the most people think I think
sobbing her [ __ ] kicks the acai at us
well it's just so he's young it's like
that was thinking about with Ryan Bader
and Fedor it's like you got a guy who I
think it's when you get to be 42
whatever he is your reaction time is
just slower you're gonna get caught even
me at 35 a 5th some feel a little slower
you do you slow down your bat speed and
baseball you hit 35 just exactly when
you hit 35 if you're not supplementation
supplementing your bat speeds gonna slow
down no matter what and that's why guys
couldn't hit those fast balls as they
got older but suddenly you're 38 and
you're crushing the home runs you know
dude you know what man when you're right
you're right bro yeah so you got to take
so that's why my boxing I got to get on
TRT you loose your face clear it up dude
did you see I listen to Rogan Oh killer
boots man these are blunt stones bro
watch how you talk about blunt stones
because you're insulting all of
Australia we have a lot of Australian
fans bro yeah I've been there on tour
you've never been out there
so what them boots are terrible like
that raining loves those right now yeah
it's raining Wow how dare you Peter
Gulla and show up in them boots these
are cool boots bro sweet killer boots
man that I slip them on and I slip them
off I'm stretching my hamstrings right
now it feels nice huh yeah I can never
get my hamstrings loose I've always had
tight hamstring always at least can help
me what see that see I got you yeah see
how it works yeah but I just wanted to
help I know so you were just driving
down the road I altitude so how would
you alright so what if I here we go
I'm are you driving the pedophile yeah
and you're driving and I'll be enough
dad I'm dad oh what's wrong
we're just tight man ty we're I'm a dick
what oh it's just raging lately man
well don't you have a way to get I did
taken care of I did I just was just the
best of all what are you doing digit
screen I can see it over yeah it's the
whole thing
it's literally over here not all right
now it hurts looks like I'm some finally
just stretch my arm out it's just my arm
out right I would that thing looks super
permanent not a headache give me some
aspirin right I'll do ever I can it just
sucked me off boom is that see how you
got into the trance yeah yeah I got no
speaks in a second you'd sucked me off
this is the 70s you don't have a [ __ ]
test my bro oh no in your car bro I put
on autopilot
and you're driving I don't this is crazy
Boop I don't need pants this is my
everything to do is motor with macho
guys somebody was talking about you
being strong they said these tough
hiking fighter go what do you mean Kenny
what kind of question is that they're
used UFC heavyweight he goes yeah I mean
who the [ __ ] was it he goes um he said
who was he goes how it no he goes um
so so if he kicked your ass right away I
got my what he I go he would he could
[ __ ] you dude you know that right you're
grown man
Brendan could if he wanted he could [ __ ]
yeah dude I tell you so more than just
beat you up you know talk to Todd filmin
to do a lot of boxing which was playing
like he does jujitsu and although he's
the best and we're going to lunch I you
can tell when someone's joking like
unite joke around time he was dead so
she goes dude I'm just I'm really
curious about this he goes if I like
grabbed you like say you're just walking
to lunch and I grabbed you could I take
you down like how fast could you because
you think I could take you down if I
just like surprise you with seeing a leg
and I do you know you in telling so in
serious eyes I turn on some serious
thought he's you know it there's nothing
he could do man there's nothing so let
him try and show him I forgive him
you're like just give him your life give
him your detalls Vince is this he could
not stop laughing that's so funny you
seriously do it
no there's nothing Todd nothing could do
in the world again nothing no I told you
I went out grabbing yeah I've got a gun
twisting break so I really did try to
take you down those hilarious yeah
the party yeah you sprawled on me and my
ear was red fur just stop it just stop
being same event I cried for Tim Kennedy
I think you know what I think try to
take drugs did we do drugs then yeah we
did we did DMT was that the day that was
though are you sure yeah I'm lit through
I'm like why was I crying like that
that dude interesting hold up could not
stop cross so Brendan and I did we did
DMT we did in DMT trip we didn't know it
was a Jen I said I can't believe you
guys did that do really no team I would
do it harpy we didn't know which what
ayahuasca is we didn't know what to
expect
I'm into psychedelics now I've never
done it but I wanted to a sit next
listen if you're young and listening to
this don't i'm 52 and then no deemed
alas it i don't have a kid that was
young okay but if you're an adult it's
up to you but he was lost
DMT so I've never I'm not a drug guy
right I never loved to drive there it
another cocaine and not even weed right
not really a boozer so every city we
find out we're gonna we're gonna be
invited we're invited this quantum quote
ceremony by a shaman who will remain
nameless and yeah we're like are we
gonna do this I'm not gonna push out
well really good with each other right
so we're like alright well here goes if
I hadn't been with you I think I would
have been a [ __ ] and I would been skin
you smoke it it was to me borderline
life-changing wow I'm a big believer in
trying it then we did it again
I wanted to keep doing it me too he's
like this
I don't know so we did we did so the
first one it was like I shot off into
the heavens I was surrounded by a warm
gold cloud can I got up into like this
cool area the second one is like I was
in space almost just me too and I can
hear you and you go I heard you laughing
and you sounded like you were in another
dimension you were like huh
like does a hyena I'm serious I was
laughing so loud I'll because wool broke
chill chill I couldn't stop laughing so
I'm such a grant it was it was the most
impressive thing I thought I was there
for three days
I asked how we got down with dude how
long was the up there he goes 30 sec
what why my pants down I know it is an
incredible thing that's right I never
want us together I never put it together
you're sounding at garnet they ran they
told everything get out that's why you
think we're just doing with you guys
right 11 our old produced they wouldn't
know which can do with these guys right
you leave then the next day we have the
party I'm like dude I'm an emotional
dude I cried like I cried when I shot my
special I cried was like coming central
I cried when I bought my Raptor so of
the next day like I'm not that big of a
emotional right now
with Tim Kennedy like we did the blind
guys the pockets are and we love them
and he goes I'm just worried about him I
don't want him to die he's a great guy
go to hold on I'm talking waterworks
like I've never cried so hard in my life
I'm talking to my wife and I'm talking
on the phone I've Sunglass son and I'm
talking about him I'm like this I go I
go yeah yeah so that's good yeah all
right now but then I'll talk to you and
we'll see you in there like my dog you
want a towel or you wanna hold ya know
see you soon baby you guys yet and the
thing ya know I'll be home and then he
goes are you serious right now and I'm
like yeah I get he goes hold on Benny's
crying let me call you back he goes dude
are you [ __ ] I'm talking snot I have
to go into the party and leave him in
the car I tell Brian don't tell everyone
that I'm in here crying give me a few to
get my [ __ ] together yeah tell him I
have allergies to I walk in the foyer
was like Croydon I go Jews all right
guys Brendan mr. ion is weeping in my
car doesn't make sense though 100% yeah
because there's 100 per day night I love
Tim canes my favorite people on earth
I'll do anything for that man but I
wouldn't cry like that that's so
interesting because we had such a great
row that is residue so he interesting
that's so interesting it affected you
that deeply that makes
no I put like two weeks on Bazar does
that ever happen to you yeah I'll wake
up at like 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning
and a bit I've been working on something
well trigger and let's dude there it is
yes then the same thing I don't know why
it came to me he's like dude the reason
you were crying cuz you're on DMT I'm
like holy [ __ ] that happened four years
ago yeah yes am i dead except dat was
fun it's incredible
dude we should I knew it with more
chicks we should all thank you well
that's what ayahuasca those trips is
like all these guys were like it's gonna
that's good approve if you look around
it's like just one hot 20-something
after another in like some summer those
shaman like okay hey hey guys how's this
spiritual journey going this is an
excuse to bang no no you smoke this
ayahuasca man sucking me dry guys every
guy it's all one big excuse to bang its
think guys fight bulls cuz they want
chicks - life is coming up maybe we
should do a little DMT with our brain
get weird let me show you DMT and we're
math and freak each other you know it
did just man say something and then
relieve my you can't stop talking about
you know you talk calm again you can't
stop talking about sucking relieving
tension you know and now you the giant
wants me to wear a mask and urs and you
want to do DMT just my firt and you're
looking at me like a hawk it's a my bird
it's the blue I'm not into the furtive a
guy guy on guy it's love no no I said
that's what you wouldn't ask we invite a
bunch of I don't know dude because you
you you my birthday picture this I'm
Batman kind of I'm not going anywhere
near you when you're on DMT full of love
and a mask on the same eyes wide shut
you don't want Olsen I'll get there and
we're all the girls ah they couldn't
make it their words I happen to me one
time let's have a guy's house a very
rich doctor he had us drop not Molly
both the other thing with what's the
thing diem doesn't like MDMA MDMA that
is mom yep yeah justice luncheon Bali
and he goes dude ton of strip this is a
while ago
we're all in the hot tub my brother's
there Cody
all fighters Network ton of big spiders
studs we all drop Molly a ton of it
because girls are coming by the
truckload it's like sweet we're all
[ __ ] shredded this is this is a
doctor friend doctor yeah and we're all
we always had we're suspect that he like
guys are all young lions it yeah a lot
younger age engaging yeah yeah in the
hot tub we're all sitting around and fun
and my brother goes we're all high as
[ __ ] - no my brother guess he's got a
preggers there's the chick that we're
all hi were like yeah where are all the
girls anything he goes they should be
here man I don't know when they come in
he goes but they don't show I mean he
goes like this who the doctor goes but
they don't show Wow my brother he goes
the [ __ ] does that mean it's called the
claptrap
that's called a [ __ ] dude you're caught
on his conquest no girl showed up he's
got one girl showed up whips full of
dongs now yeah one female showed up yeah
that guy's clearly was well a lot of I
mean listen you guys are all there or
you're all young lions that never happen
how funny is that Jay we're all the
girls all the girls yeah yeah generally
speaking with his impossible dog you
really girls that night that rule ah
yeah we're all think of it I have all
these kinship feelings for my friends
yeah man we need to DMT again dude what
are we gonna do for my birthday man
when's your birthday again
March 18th I'm in Miami this 14th
through the 16th we should do something
students you know you should come Miami
and get you a Brazilian butt lift I have
a great note would be sick we blow it
out loud like a Nicki Minaj I have a
great little ass I need to have my ass
lifted now is it a butt lift or do you
get the implants yeah no no they inject
your butt with fat would you ever do
anything like trying to feel like you
have a flat ass I do our flight house
I feel like Madonna actually
did do that right do we have any better
pictures of her ass now that she's Jim
would you do that or do you don't care
about your ass P I don't care about my
ass ah
Kat would you ever do anything like that
see if I didn't mind surgery probably
but I do I don't like the thought of
going under so I'd rather just do squats
or have a flat ass actually butt shots
maybe but then it leaks and it's a
hot-ass mess I think that's a terrible
idea
um have you felt one no I haven't you
have not mad at him
that's her butt huh oh yes she clear
that she is not gonna go gently in the
night that one is good she refuses by
the time not today bro I'll let you know
when I'm ready to give it up yeah she is
gonna do everything she can stay as
young and I bet she's a nightmare oh god
is that a real picture yeah it's real
bro that is crazy
nightmare in the sack I know people who
did you know you always say that every
time we mention and you know they say
good things
Wow well age age is what it is but they
do that thing with their face though Oh
Tom I thought they'd pull it back like
there's like at like yeah not Kat like
well the number of people that I do
Botox I mean I don't know girl the dies
angles crazy yeah I know it grows 22
does it come on gorgeous since she
doesn't like why are you doing doing
would you ever get you think that you
will ancients don't get wrinkles
you don't have one wrinkled chin I do
have a lot of wrinkles weird way in
forehead yeah that's life though that's
just where you're born you don't have
like you don't have like yeah I like me
and Brian f like brenes all the crows
feeders
I got a few of a brightness all the
crows you have no wrinkles cat yeah it's
like boom like a porcelain plate nothing
I know nothing a porcelain I know she's
a young hold you 23 my porcelain plates
like I know you know that's one but
still you'd have some I had that face
when I was 23
no I've seen your face bro I had that
exact
said these wrinkles young I was a young
Vietnamese cow and I had things down
look at that
but you see though how you've had the
wrinkles up top well that was when I was
thirty they're cute though oh that was
when I was 40 not bad Wow now is uh yeah
thirty I was 36 they're things I rap Oh
buddy remember that that's fun
feels like forever ago yeah do I see a
picture from five years ago when you're
doing press for finding the kid in New
York who is that wow that guy looks like
he needs release from a man yeah that's
looks like I'm wearing eye makeup I had
nice-looking Mike look at how different
my nose was then my nose your nose
getting bigger huh come bulbous do I
like the baggy dad suit there yeah yeah
I'm a cutie pie from comedy too strong
too
Oh from them I spent a lot of my life
being a pretty good-looking guy I'm not
gonna lie to you oh yeah you're a good
like back then you're dime a dozen but
for a grope for older men you're good
looking
tomorrow a better older man really young
all right I'll take that yeah I think it
stopped for men to look good older you
all look better older yeah you sure I
think so especially in entertainment a
hundred percent yeah well men are lucky
that way as they get older there's a
there's a whole market no men age I'm on
it
wine yeah women age like fruit I've
heard that before
or cheese cheese this this guy on
Rogen's podcasters a longevity
specialist at Harvard University he was
talking about some crazy [ __ ] about how
they can take mice they crush their
optic nerves they blind them that must
be nice for the lice yeah I know but
then they they shoot them up with a
virus that that cures their optic nerve
so they they go from they have shitty
eyes ready to go from blind design to
seeing well we shoot up some blind
people well that's what they're doing
they have these trials they're
regenerating eyes not only this have a
plan event of taking old mice they're
giving them drugs
jeopardy drugs that are essentially what
they think age does is like say you have
a DVD player your DVD player gets your
DVD gets scratched yeah they're taking
these scratches out of it
it's so [ __ ] weird so they have these
young mice and they're kind of reversing
the age process process David Sinclair
it was fascinating
now he's 52 and he takes various drugs
longevity drugs that they're working on
he's 52 with it's common when you're 50
here but maybe it's not when your while
you're a hundred you know we're gonna
look 50 you and I technically when were
100 could be what a 55 65 year old is
more me than you be I hear you that's
true that's very true he about catzilla
forever
yeah yeah is genetics professor and
co-director of the Palo friend Center
for biology of aging he's 50 there yeah
at Harvard University he doesn't like 50
doesn't I know his brother is gray and
everything but he takes these drugs and
they just keep him really young [ __ ]
nuts and his genetics are not good he
has a heart disease in his family and
everything else but and he talks about
medicine like we talk about medicine but
it's a molecule well no but you want
what you want is to be like bust health
until you're a hundred that would be
nice what do you want to do you can you
want it yeah you want to be robust
healthy a hundred so even if your dad a
hundred you're still living you feel
life you feel good you don't be on your
bed till you're when you're eight and
that's the idea that's good aging is a
disease that's one talks about really
[ __ ] em n em I'm gonna look good stuff
I'm excited about it I know I was too
rewinding the car clock Harvard Medical
School
well whatever J Lo's Dave look at this
they've discovered a way to reverse
vascular agent by boosting the response
to whatever it is [ __ ] who went to
Harvard he's at Harvard he ever teaches
at Harvard never heard of it teaches he
was talking about that he goes I'm the
word doctors worst nightmare because I
teach doctors so when they give my tests
I'm like I know but this is not what I'm
teaching him look at this they've
restored vessel growth and mice and
nerve growth and he said this [ __ ] is
happening so much faster than he thought
you know why there are governments and
countries that are full-bore on this
[ __ ]
gene-editing China does yeah wait they
don't wait the problem is that obviously
they're trying to do it with that
certain they might be doing it with
certain bacterial viruses you know
that's an X that can wipe out - hey
that's a nice just get a hold of the flu
we're all scary we have some current
events
wait chin Cal would you guys do this
weekend can't you just work like a
[ __ ]
yep work where CIL's that's it
rehearsals going well yeah
when's the final ones to play this
weekend Oh what day um Friday Saturday
and Sunday it's on I'm in San Diego
Thursday Friday Saturday come see me at
the American comedy club life hold on
how about Sunday Sunday
what about what time on Sunday it's got
a - yeah I'd have to drive back I might
do it where is it it's at cam but it's
weird I wasn't even able to get tickets
it's like a weird sign up family buy
tickets or no no it's all it's free but
it's like on a wait list I don't know I
couldn't even get my boyfriend in oh
it's him and you're in it yeah where is
cam it's right across from us see it's
the California african-american Museum
[Music]
what I'm becoming this I think I Drive
right by there from on my way back from
San Diego oh cool you're not going so
why are you bullshitting Kat I was
celebrity I'll just go and go hey guys I
know this waitlist but have you seen my
face hey guys I'm an actor hey Jay I was
gonna go on Friday or Saturday we can't
go now I guess not I didn't even know
about it
they told us after the fact that they
had people signed up already
dang I love please I want to go Thursday
on my American comedy club Friday
Saturday I'm at American comedy club
well she can't get any tickets anyways I
have to oh that's the small club in San
Diego right
[ __ ] mean and yeah yeah pretty
electric small stage gene what'd you do
this weekend
this weekend I'm not let's talk about
two weeks ago
remember I didn't tell you that I went
to the hospital to get checked up for
yeah my nose how about doing below the
belt and Unitas Chin's like this dude
with Josie plenteous I thought it was
just running whoa
there's blood all over his face I will
no sir
yeah and he was what and is there blood
on my face man well yeah dude I looked
at my hand I thought I was like just
doing this and then everyone inside just
like what's going on you okay okay I'm
like yeah that's fine I thought it's
just regular just ready knows this is
blood going I have no idea so you myself
doctor you know what to get checked up
on everything my blood count is kind of
low that's the one thing that's not good
what your red blood cells yeah CBC's
will the total the complete one CBC says
red blood cells are a little low but uh
my nose thing was just an allergy they
did all these tests they're like it has
to be from an allergy cuz they looked
inside it wasn't anything like weird do
I feel like I could look inside your
nose
I know let me check good but uh she gave
me this uh little thing your blood
counts low yeah oh that's your anemic I
guess so but when they so I went twice
cuz they checked the first time they
said OHS low let's check again yeah and
then when they checked again that says
it's still low but it's like not within
it's not crazy low so it's okay
stand up for a second let me do a little
yeah well I you know I have some
experience with this hmm okay now hold
on now trust me yeah your blood count is
low take your pants off for a second I
want to see you can tell it was anything
else wrong chin no I did everything so I
did liver panel cuz never I told you I
need to do that oh you should it you
feel a lot better
you definitely yeah I need to do it
myself
oh yeah my nose bleeding's not good had
a doctor like this about four years ago
he goes huh some of the new blood south
looks good um unis m'q oh my go
know when you go what news no nothing
just something a little low but I think
it's gonna be okay
Firebird seems good know one thing he's
feeling my neck he goes he goes on a
checkup I know what that told me this
mmm
I was a little bit bigger than normal
maybe because I don't think it's cancer
anything's don't worry I go [ __ ] dude
what are you talking one up yet so I got
a thing is nice fighting Gabriel Gonzaga
in Anaheim the California it might is
either California Jersey there
Commission's are super strict so you
have to get more than just blood work
something you just have to blood work
you get to do a full MRI cat scan your
brain everything they check everything a
man had to go get like an MRI and a cat
scan on my brain the doctor comes in you
know they had the papers and he's
flipping through us yeah you see
everything's all good
oh we did find a tumor in the base of
your brain but I know but I'll keep an
eye on it and then let's see here you're
also I'm like oh my god he goes yeah we
said you saw tumor it was did see a
little tumor to act your brain but it's
benign so it's probably not gonna grow
you probably have that since you were a
kid nothing to be alarmed about but I
would keep an eye on it and what I'll do
that how do i I am and I love users and
then other than that you should be all
set to fight in the steel cage and i'ma
start crying why you got my cart why go
oh my god with my in do you guys always
take fish oil yeah a baby tumor it
didn't hear your pituitary maybe that's
why you're such a giant no I'm not like
Bigfoot Silva sits in the back here Oh a
little baby to me they said if it did
flare up I would have issues yeah they
can't remove it though
game over cuz your dyers out the anthony
said so that's why sometimes you go I
don't think I'm very thoughts I say that
yeah yeah now my family knows they
didn't know before what's home boy has a
tumor I
get up for to me it's but I know baby
it's all gravy
I knew that do you tell me that a long
time ago
I've never sold anybody out there in the
ether I've never told anybody ever that
yeah they say it pushes on the clan that
makes your dick huge what is a good kind
of tumor so l1 of El Chapo's daughters
has released a clothing line inspired by
her father it's smart man there's so
many dumbass is wearing El Chapo shirts
and save El Chapo mr. el chapo like if
you're the family you own all his rights
why not capitalized I guess so right
dumb asses buy this stuff but there you
go did she post me of it yeah but it
looks like it was taken down yeah they
can't see what's we hear again there
yeah it's not interesting now did they
sensing do they sentence him yet no I
think he's in all the years available
yeah well they yeah there's a lot of
stuff where he she get the maximum
present the present a hundred I believe
that I believe that I yeah this this all
in drug trade is so endemic that's why
you should just if I were Mexico I'll
make it legal I go you know what it's
legal you guys the ones that buy it over
the border you guys who wants to support
it
we're dying we're all [ __ ] dying for
your habit so you know what make it
legal agree I don't know why they don't
make it legal damn there's no picture of
her clothing line though look for it it
has to be tough dude his kids run that
cartel now told you announcing what sure
go get dicey dicey ya know his wife is
that a ton of work done she's pretty
easy on the eyes this years hmm no feel
nurturer I'm not saying anything she's
scared huh yep anyhoo wow he's going to
prison for a very long time
yeah who's gonna go to prison longer him
Rick Takashi six nine oh that's a
current events here but uh for now so
Liam Neeson recently did an interview
where he talked about a
he had a loved one that he I don't he
doesn't specify who it is in his life
but there was a woman that he was very
close to that told him that she was
raped while he was away and she said
that it was a black guy he said that she
handled it very well for somebody who
was just raped but for about two weeks
he went out looking to see it if there
were any black guys who would start
something with him just out around pubs
like any drunk guys so he could kill
somebody and now he's getting some
backlash I don't know why he did this
but he admitted this in this interview
for the first time like he's never told
me and never admitted his impulse to
anyone before and he had that he's now
deeply ashamed of his erection a woman's
rape you know what's interesting about
this is I'm not just fine I don't think
it's right but when I was in Chicago I
jumped in a taxi and there was this
Muslim dude in there and we're just
talking great guy real Chatty Cathy but
great guy gave a great tip because he
was awesome and he's just very outgoing
and he goes yeah I'm just life's good
now man which I'm just getting over the
hump he was I used to be a taxi driver
in Chicago I had to take a number of
years off because cuz after September
11th man [ __ ] is rough out here for
people they didn't care if we were in
Isis for not if you were Muslim they
were so angry towards any Muslim he was
seeks to seek so a lot of my parents he
was a lot of my friends got beat up and
he goes in people were like throwing
stuff at me I pick him up I got punched
in the ear I got punched in the face cuz
so I got away from it who's I just got
back in and finally now it's all good
man people being nice to us so I think
with Liam Neeson again I'm not saying
it's okay but you so upset this friend
was raped when he can single out a
certain kind of demographic you can take
the anger out direct it towards how
something since he's admitting this it's
not it's not a race thing he's saying I
was human and I had a I'm ashamed to
admit that this is how I felt we will we
want to target something when something
like that happens you you're so upset
that you're you know you're gonna you're
gonna be out of your mind all but he put
here he goes I went up and down areas
with a hoping I'd be approached by
somebody I'm Sheamus a at that and I did
it for maybe a week hoping that some may
put air quotes with his fingers
basser's would come out of a pub have a
go at me or something you know so I
could kill him so aggressive but I did
learn a lesson from it when I eventually
thought what the [ __ ] are you doing you
know I come from a society I grew up in
Northern Ireland in the troubles and you
know I knew a couple of guys that died
on hunger strike and I had acquaintances
who are caught up in the troubles and I
loved the one they say the troubles and
I understand that need for revenge it
also just leaves some more revenge and
more killing and more killing and
Northern Ireland's proof of that yep ugh
I have four and I mixed the whole world
who said that an eye for an eye makes
the whole world blind Jesus No
Oh [ __ ] Dalai Lama no [ __ ] Mother
Teresa no you're doing all right no
Malcolm X no he was from India let India
- Dandi yes let India - their God let's
go get you their independence over the
English British good man important [ __ ]
man but to the partition of India that's
weird that he's coming out now and
saying the story yeah he did it in the
middle of a press junket which was kind
of odd because usually they're typically
boring I think he was trying to say that
that you know it was a mistake yeah he
didn't do it and that everybody
including me can have prejudicial
thoughts and beyond the ego feels are so
stupid I was looking for that black
bastard in quotes wait how stupid was I
yeah I think it probably inhuman it's
called being human it probably came out
and he didn't realize that he was going
into the story because the reporter who
did the interview reach out to him a
couple days later to get some more
details and he refused to say anything
so I think maybe in the spur of the
moment he just felt like talking about
it I think I think that we should be
forgiving of anybody who expresses a
time in their life when they were
traumatized and reacted in the wrong way
okay like Brian's piss me off and I go
I'm gonna kill that white bass right
yeah yeah but I don't mean it well quite
that's why to pass that hot yeah what
else we yet so did you guys hear about
21 Savage being arrested by ice yes
because he's all originally was here on
a work visa from
no he was actually born in Atlanta
Georgia on record ice has it that he is
originally from the UK and he came here
legally in 2005 and overstayed his visa
which would have ended in 2006 and has
been here ever since but he's been he
was born in Atlanta Georgia according to
him and so right now we're like what's
happened he's detained by ice right now
and there have been a bunch of memes and
jokes coming out and Demi Lovato came
out on Twitter and said that her
favorite part of the Super Bowl
yesterday were all the 21 savage memes
because I would be like he did an
interview with I believe vogue where he
had a little segment saying that he
loves to wear his yellow jacket during
crumpets and tea and people blew that up
and got mad at Demi for laughing at
jokes like that because they say it's
not funny for him to be detained by ice
and she deactivated her Twitter yeah to
be fair the memes were good and let's
talk wait so she likes the memes I
thought they were funny all the means
and [ __ ] ain't funny when somebody's
going through some praying for my dog
ain't [ __ ] funny his family its family
not fan family its family depending on
him I mean so there's a lot of celebrity
ofter yeah mm-hmm and then a lot of a
lot of fans went after her joking about
her drug overdose as well yes good for
her yeah she just had that OD and he got
out of rehab for her to throw shade at
Twitter its own shade though she's just
kind of joking around though it was
funny yeah I think she does not always
oh yes so uh what is it so 21 savage was
what what were the memes they got
arrested
I just stupid [ __ ] like yeah [ __ ] off
everybody's too sensitive [ __ ] off all
you oh yeah you know what happened these
obviously you can't you can't go out ice
on social media so they decided to point
anger towards Demi Lovato mm that's what
they're doing since listen that's
because he supposed to be from Atlanta
Georgia
this whole thing comes from the trap
city would Lana George all that stuff
and then he's British another guy with
he's British
that's why I stuck them I don't work me
that's pretty this is a guy one tattoos
on his face good stuff that's what the
kids are doing man yeah I can't get with
it whatever [ __ ] off everybody you
sensitive [ __ ] okay if I know it's a
noise no the interesting looking fella
is that his real face yes I've been an
elevator with that man haven't we had
the same sponsor and that's interesting
yeah you probably get in trouble if I
said what he was talking about on the
phone it was very interesting that way
oh wow oh wow this is a elevator full of
people who heard everything he just said
what was he saying he was not enough
about he was it was not good about what
he's gonna do what he did
oh and it was not good okay or like okay
well it's a knife miss a knife people
are funny all right what else he had I
don't give a [ __ ] about him oh it's this
so the polar vortex is happening over in
Chicago right now and there was a woman
who used her money to pay for hotel
rooms for the homeless who didn't have a
place to stay and people caught wind of
this or a GoFundMe to help her pay for
all of these rooms for people to stay in
yeah because people do you know it's
colder there than the north they are oh
yeah so crazy
well I said my money said over six yeah
my buddy says 47 minus 47 nobody
realizes that cold that I mean oh that's
so crazy
it takes six minutes to get frostbite
and if they say if you if you walk out
with your eyes on like protected if
they're not protecting your eyes of
freeze so like people are everyone's
with the [ __ ] like she'll wear
contacts that's like it's crazy man Oh
joining us cousins of Chicago writer
Graham is that there yeah and he was
check this out and she sends it's a
video he's watched outside he has a full
thing of steaming hot coffee throws in
the air
as it's going it freezes in the air no
way yeah
there's a videos like this and it
freezes no way hard so that's boiling
water he took a hot coffee for sure cut
out the although this is wild come on no
so it just looks like powder ice thrown
up in the air are you kidding me that's
so crazy that's crazy
that is crazy
oh my god that's crazy
I've actually never I'm actually blown
away by that for anything yo yeah
what else are yet hmm see so there is a
ancestry company who distributes those
tests I believe their name is family
tree your family tree dude yeah Family
Tree DNA they actually just started
working with the FBI and turning over
DNA that they get from their customers
to help for FBI investigations and
that's similar to how the Golden Gate
killer was caught yeah that's right if
you're gonna catch a serial killer or a
child molester or slash killer pedophile
um I get it to solve crimes almost yeah
yeah like that wouldn't use my D lines
like that you know to make sure I'm not
the killer right go ahead and use my 21
in me correct
don't DNA's put a lot of [ __ ] behind
bars this gets a little tricky you don't
have to go to the dick doctor and do a
deposit right and I was thinking myself
what do they do with all that yeah I
know they're not taking my 20 and
selling it at black mark 23 really this
guy six for 240 pounds pretty friendly
but they investigated 23andme they've
been they've been really responsible
really I mean they said come on in any
time you want with everybody you want
we'll show you exactly what we do and
they're really after I need to do that
and so you know
but this is the future you your DNA your
genetic imprint is not only going to be
used to prolong your life it'll be used
to help your children it'll be used to
edit your genes you'd have to worry
about dumb [ __ ] like heart disease and
diabetes did the Chinese twins in China
he made those twins resistant to HIV
dude I went to a song with God i BF
doctor to it so if me my grown have
twins or whatever you want to do so he
can get pregnant right away yeah they go
oh what do you have in your family go
they do all your blood workup diabetes
cancer they can take all that out you
want to boy you on a girl you want to
boys you want to girls
what do you want what Christian did that
you do it yeah that's the tip of the
spear with Chris forecast 9 if you want
to have a black baby you could have a
black baby if you wanted to have a baby
with I mean eventually you want a baby
with no with the no genetic
predisposition to heart disease to
cancer to anything all that stuff no
spinal bifida crazy
you get resolved all the ceremony pools
know what they do is they find the
strongest sperm that was healthy with
zero problems they just take him out put
them in the egg cheese yep crazy min
what else you get this here designer
babies so jay-z and beyonce have a vegan
challenge going on right now where they
are encouraging their fancy go vegan for
a certain amount of time 10 days right
no I think that was J Lo's r1 yeah
I think this one's like 2022 days J Lo's
there's no carbs no sugar for days I'll
do it and they said if you post up
photos from this challenge and you're
picked then you can get free tickets to
their concert concerts for a lifetime
but a lifetime means the next 30 years
[ __ ] yeah tickets for next 30 years I
don't have to be the biggest fan
Chieko I dig in diet for 22 days hoping
to get tickets hit what is it she has a
video what's this my green print man
just pictures me there's my nose so
they're both they're both vegan I don't
know that mm-hmm Wow cool
Jay Jay Z looks like Joe the cam off he
had [ __ ]
both herb yeah I mean me forever forever
I'll cut down on my red meat apparently
this longevity guys once they tell me
that it's horrible for you I probably
cut down on it I still drink diet coke
for God's sake that's not that bad
broken that some scientists on the guy
was like ask Brett I mean if if it was
really bad people who drink die coke
would be dying by the droves there's no
example of that there's no everyone does
it everyone's right now see the
aspartame that that they gave to rats
you couldn't take that much as a human
being it was so over the top I was like
god yeah you feel like when I drink it
I'm killing myself [ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm
addicted to my thing so drink my mouth
is addicted drink it I just think some
of this stuff is [ __ ] off dude I don't
know what is I just I don't drink any
liquor nothing I got so much beer
yesterday I touched one of them and I
was like I just can't
yeah I don't think I'm not I'm not the
drinking guy either anymore I used to
drink a bottle of wine one glass of wine
that's all I need wanna be though man
feel like I just would like a cool
whiskey people come visit me I got a
cardigan on like this my chains out yeah
how you doing yeah just a nice little
smoker get you some to drink well that's
what I call a snifter yeah a snifter you
got any family members that that like to
drink a little too much cuz I do and I
got some you do as well oh you know
you'll have a and I'll have a cousin or
just some cousin and we'll all get
together on the thing they always be
that one guy was like you want to drink
some more
no too much jello snifter going I got to
pee bad go for it
so ariana grande just released her new
single seven rings and she got a tattoo
on her palm to commemorate it
she got seven rings written in kanji
which is Japanese and it was actually
misspelled because she couldn't do all
of the characters it hurt too much she
stopped and it spelled out - barbecue
grill oh yes I heard about and even when
she got a fixed loved it it was I
spelled correctly it's still not good it
came out to Japanese barbecue finger
that's awkward yes
I love it loving people [ __ ] up their
tattoos she got it right here on her
hand right mm-hmm it'll fade away man
that's gonna fade really bad too you
ever seen people get tattoos on their
feet or their hands they've made like
that it doesn't last Oh
as we get [ __ ] him I can't believe
our hard in the paint
Levine went with tattoos his whole back
everything crazy man you like it I mean
dude how about Ariana Grande Zach's the
great Pete Davidson is [ __ ] Kate
Beckinsale [ __ ] really yeah dude
really
he's originator big dick energy I guess
just has a massive piece oh the [ __ ] man
congratulations Kate Beckinsale is so
hot
painfully hot he's got vulnerable he's
the vulnerable type I know they dig him
what else you got this fur here so
you're talking about to cost you six
nine so he pled guilty to let me see his
face please yeah sure all the tattoos
all right listen I was a mess well he's
super famous rap star now I mean one of
the biggest yeah huge but uh so he has
like ties to a gang and he admitted so
as part of his plea deal he admitted to
being a part of this really violent gang
and then he also admitted to trying to
help them kill someone hold on the
rapper whose legal name is Daniel
Hernandez he's Mexican apparently I made
a federal court hearing in Manhattan be
a member of the ninth ray gangster
Bloods said he's helped other gang
members rob people at gunpoint and when
Kay said I helped members of ninth ray
attempt to kill a rival gang member
I didn't maintain or increased my own
standing in ninth ray Oh said the gang
engaged in shooting at people robbing
people and at times drug trafficking so
let me tell us stupid this is for a kid
like this he's worth 20 million dollars
and you're doing this [ __ ] because
they're trying to live this like
gangsters ivory legit trying to be legit
mm-hmm he's also working with the feds
because he's hoping to get a lesser
sentence that's what he's doing all this
and
the weird thing the crazy thing that
Ronnie thing is he's 22 years old right
now right so the minimum sentence he
would get if he didn't do this plea deal
it's 47 years so 47 plus 22 they say
nine they say now he's probably gonna
get like six years oh damn they say he's
gonna get four to six years in federal
pen
yeah and they had to take him out of the
prison who are the Josie I say cuz the
gang affiliation he's also being a
snitch that's not so tiny yes yeah he's
tiny
oh he's a little guy it has a terrible
body no his girl's so hot though Yeah
right there yeah but how crazy is it it
would have been 69 years he would read
out when he was 69 if he deaf he'll be
out in six of it and they don't care
about your celebrity you still a boy 22
alright so this is a David or Dave
Portnoy yeah the head of Barcelona's god
I know Dave well I guess he had some
issue with Roger Goodell
do you know anything about they had a
shirt that with Roger Goodell as a clown
that they sold and then I felt tried
halting all sales oh so that's the real
so Goodell like verbally yeah well it's
Barstow he had a C he had his press
credentials revoked right no yeah he was
he was not allowed in any NFL game
anything to do with NFL anymore but then
he got into the Super Bowl press
conference right I don't forgot to the
press conference but he was I saw him at
the press conference I saw a masked
hombre de question I think it was Gronk
or Tom Brady and they're like what the
[ __ ] is that Belichick laughing we're
right there can you go back is there a
video of Belichick laughing a dad joke
it's not him no but that's I mean that's
him behind and they are now it's gone
here's other videos question they kicked
him out right yeah boy I heard halftime
update the emergency press conference on
our
merciful Father since operate one
Rosello shop now sin just poured into
the ground oh not that poverty best ever
do it but that have sucked it feels like
you should be making ten thirty nothing
I mean it makes me very nervous we're
being honest the programs have like
negative infinity yards and it's only
three Nuggets I gotta believe Brady will
play better I have to believe that
everything I know is a human believes
that I'm nervous I think it's come down
to the end just like it always does I
think we'll win but he's a boss some
kids Brady yeah I'd like you to show up
in the second half dude dad I'm asking
hey talk Super Bowl going on let's show
up let's get number six that's all I ask
I think we'll get if we get their
defense just what hats on half let's go
that's him there hey sounds great I like
that guy yeah they're my boys him and
cave [ __ ] what is this I hope the video
is still up but it looks like it's team
gone yeah yeah yeah that's him you know
like in cuffs but I don't think it's
actual cuffs is probably just a security
cuffs that's funny
fake mustache fake mustache so he made
it in there yeah that's security kicking
them out I'm arguing with him yeah
[Music]
and Goodell can kick him out for that
well he was banned from yeah they can
ban you there's a part where he's
actually getting dragged out from the
seats the audience seats in this made of
I just might keep sleeping that's them
dragging them haha that's all there he
knows the cameras are on so he makes it
even worse he's Valley oh goodness
that's a hard job for those guys buddy
so yeah he actually made it in there you
snuck in maybe they can find you yeah
alright so this is another one I don't
know I said another one but this is
another attempt to get insurance money
what is miserable someone put is that
really all you got yeah it's so bad
player for you
where's this at it's his it's at his
workplace but how exactly where it is
but let's take a look real quick so he
grabs ice he's not young he doesn't know
that those on the ground he doesn't know
that he's on camera mm-hmm and even the
way he falls you don't listen
God what a [ __ ] well yeah wait and then
look his hand he finally drops his
little thing is he what a [ __ ]
yeah get better at feeling you're being
a fraudster pal he threw ice in the
floor I first say guys should be ashamed
if this is really asbestos time to fake
and slip and fall injury I mean what
they do they just fire him
no I think you can get sued for fraud he
was arrested in January is now facing
fraud yeah you have to be arrested for
that you know these people who do this
stuff for such [ __ ] and they cost
companies a lot of money New Jersey it's
not the first time he's done [ __ ] like
this oh let's get it your mo that's your
mo your that your dad people do that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah you know you're 57 things haven't
worked out used to do that subcontractor
and a wood bridge company what when you
right you're right Brian thanks buddy
post uh I should have sent to you guys
[ __ ] what
post this one man let me find out why
you wait me and Brian takes each other
so much I'll find it in here okay
dude you didn't text me back when I sent
you my picture my [ __ ] truck either
bro that'll make me feel good I didn't
know [ __ ] you really yeah [ __ ] I'm sorry
no don't be sorry
I don't know what to say yeah just empty
Jim put that up after this alright well
this is just an update on that guy Jesse
Smollett oh yeah what happened that guy
so this is the guy from power right
Empire by this guy oh that this is very
interesting to me because he wouldn't be
with ya racist remember he wouldn't give
us four over to the cops that's
interesting so and they want to check
the phone records you were talking to
your agent 2:00 a.m. they say he's
starting this is agent really at 2:00
a.m.
hmm can we check your phone records the
latest the people buying it because I
started it a did a performance yesterday
and he's crazy I'm just happy to be here
so he did a performance recently where
he cleared up some of the rumors he
wanted to make it very clear that he did
not have any ribs broken that they were
bruised and that they were that he
wasn't hospitalized that after the
attack he went to a doctor and he got
checked out yeah he also wanted
everybody to know that he fought back
and then he continued to claim that he's
the gay to puck he said he fought the
[ __ ] back I fought the [ __ ] back and
everyone cheered and they have did he
have didn't he didn't he have that noose
around his neck and he went home with it
on there was me take it off right away
there was a witness that said that they
saw somebody within that area two men
holding a rope and they found
surveillance footage of two guys that he
says were the attackers that's the
latest I came out really but he also
wouldn't turn over his phone to police
he called his agent and he that might
just also because he's got like dick
pics on yeah he's a nice you know what
the cops seen all your business you
might be banging just
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] if he
gives a phone records that's then we'll
know that story then however they did
indicate that they were able to get his
cell phones blue print it within that
area and so it does place him with it
it was he wasn't lying about where he
was he was in the area yeah but they can
look at phone records too they could
subpoena phone records which I don't
know if they would but they could
literally say were you talking to your
agent at that time see when you say
these things cops investigate they you
can't cover all your bases they're
professional I don't know if I'm buying
it one more thing that I saw I don't
know how accurate this is but so
apparently he still had this sandwich in
his hand when he went back to his place
so after he fought back after you got
attacked and got that whatever bleach
thrown his face apparently still it
grabbed a sandwich afterwards and took
it with him man I'm sighs I'm just my
nose is out my nose is out because they
still haven't found where is the for
surveillance what you guys do we haven't
you physically have the news let's see
this this most recent so we don't have
any evidence so check him out at his
before bit like black Twitter's question
it - it's not race Oh a lot of people
even like do it race I don't know
anything about that you know I'm just
suspicious cuz he was out at 2:00 a.m.
during the polar vortex oh but there's
also another thing you know he did a
music video with a noose around his neck
and with Trump anti-trump thing right
yeah we know though he did a music video
where he had a board there was an anti
truck thing and then in there but I
don't know if there was a noose or
something but there was an anti trying
that getting all this info Brennen I'm
just getting pieces now she doesn't do
any research and now he's in West
Hollywood
I told you what his peeves like what's
what check him out at this concert that
he did a week after the attack my little
sister's really like Olivia Pope and
we're not Roman they will not break
I went to the doctor immediately
that's Andrew you know I was not
hospitalized why is he reading both my
doctors in LA and Chicago cleared me to
perform but said to take care of history
and above all
[Applause]
we do a performance after this look at
how dramatic years yeah and then listen
to his last night well not
[Applause]
this is being silly there I like that
hum the gate to buy that's funny that's
good he's got a good sense of here but
no one knows I mean look man I'm sure
the guy is in many ways a great dude and
talented and we probably love him but
you might be lying right yeah I'm not
buying it right oh there's still some
more tickets I get some more I just
don't see if he's if he is lying it's
gonna be very embarrassing so I don't
know yeah
what's the Hollywood let me read this
TVs Longview this The Hollywood Reporter
ever heard of it
the masked senior isn't the only
mid-season rating star scroll down chin
right there strong so it goes through
them America's Got Talent
ever heard of it huge show schooled the
spin-off of the Goldbergs has been
performing almost exactly like well the
Goldberg oh yeah early in its life with
3-day averages of 1.6 in the 18 to 49
demo and 5.5 million viewers school is
holding on to better than 90% of its
lead-in and parent show audience a
better rate than American housewife one
point four or five point four million
and we went up by we've gone up 8% dude
it's a hit brothers crazy right
congratulate and thank you buddy I'm
happy I'm happy
I appreciate it was like a big deal
thank you yeah deal men certainly from
me feels good it feels good for everyone
in here to thank you guys I appreciate
how long for equidistant podcast because
this will last for ever and it's fun and
too important into my Bimmer until my
tumor goes here let's go Homer it's rose
and your dick it's so big you can't
[ __ ] walk around I really walk around
that's cool though right schooled yeah
America's Got Talent
and schools on it's on Wednesday nights
right yeah why is it that 8:30
I love you know what I really love
watching it with my kid to watch my
daughter live the best
I actually absolutely love that kids
watch it and come up to me and they're
so excited I never get tired I'm in no
we're gonna like - I love your show
anyway yeah he did a music video yeah
you see Trump in the background but it
was like a it's very like a masked Trump
I mean that mean I think taraj EP Henson
put it up right on this graph
I like taraji hold up my brother so
bezel if you know you know Jay he's
balls deep in that stuff when it comes
to we text so much so I don't know where
it's at none of you want to be on the
view you would do I can make the hack
out for you maybe go to black Twitter
Jen I don't know what that is
dude how about Hussein Balt run enough
for 340 he did Hussein Balt ran a 42
Ford didn't warm up or anything went oh
this is the NFL Combine Oh check this
out and just warmed up and run afford to
do what yo Jesus Jim that dove to see I
must see that I find taraji very
attractive and awesome talented John
Locke yes all right love oh here it is
Jeff on it here we go Deacon's you can
sing
[Music]
god he could say I don't care if he's
lying I like him I'll take chin over him
really no we really have a similar voice
do I yeah no I guess not
well that's a video of him I just sent
you guys the thing where people are
questioning it cuz I know that's random
that he's in that music video and then
this happens to him to promote it a
little bit yeah
who knows I don't think he's a bad guy
just think it's clumsy you think he was
trying to be political and bring down
Trump like that girl with her hairy
tattoo yeah I like to remember that girl
the tattoo or me I thought of yeah all
fake
she's do it for public or she came out
said that we called it yeah she's
awesome
yeah tight move yeah yeah he might have
been just trying to get back at Trump in
his own way and well but also promote
you have you ever heard of him before
this no I have it
have you guys there you go now yeah he's
a watch on fire so that was the thing
Brendan just said over that was it the
video clip so you're right there's a
noose on the side of that dude right
yeah this music video came out before
the attacks mmm or the attack just it's
just the coincidence on a SantaFe I'm
saying there's a lot of similarities and
people are calling [ __ ] I don't care
either way all right dude cool man
at least he's okay at least didn't
really get hurt if it did happen well if
it did happen I'm if it didn't happen
then yeah he that's not quest don't
think he's a good dude even if he's
[ __ ] I don't I don't dislike him
okay okay it's tough to get [ __ ]
media this day and age you got a single
coming out on your show whatever all
right I wouldn't do it oh you're lying
you're a lot of you're a liar yet again
I don't hear and you're polarizing
watches show them I don't watch it
anyway but well he'll pay a price if
he's faking I mean in a way I mean
this'll be very it came out by this will
be sorry if it was totally I feel like
it came out by cops will not give up I
mean really no the cops will find out
although what the cops are gonna do is
they going
he made a statement so when you make a
statement they cross-check you were
talking to who when good so we have know
what happens with cops as they go we
can't find any evidence so they have
already formulated their point can they
say it's fake yeah how do you do that
well there's no other that's a crime
right you're you're you're wasting you
state resources look there's all kinds
of stuff and you are so so what happens
is they're gonna come you made a whole
statement they're gonna find out they're
gonna find out you got them on you got
the dogs on the old trail their noses
are out too but these are professional
noses and it'll give up today they don't
give the [ __ ] oh how naive I thought
they'd go do we can't funny I don't want
to look bad bad and just move on because
then they look bad I thought just move
on like we can find no sorry bro anyway
no you said there was a crime now the
Chicago get over it no easy go real
crime that celebrities find celebrity
saying he got attacked and you're saying
that this was Magga country and all that
stuff all right now they're gonna look
at this is career suicide
I'm if you faked a lot these you're
pretty good
Oh would you hire them for a movie role
if these people like this get if you
lied about something it's really really
bad lies here yes it's a bad one because
so many people are relying you on the
truth when you lie when you do this for
your own profit or whatever it might be
take your advantage of the Husky middle
Americans actually don't fly people back
to mom you take a seat for at least 10
years you know you gotta take a seat
dude what are you doin Hollywood finds
out you can't fight oh you you're not
gonna work in this house [ __ ] did you
just hit on everyone he can fight you
come on Bronco and this note and and you
got you got bling on your [ __ ] on
your chest it's on my my bag diamonds
yeah dude don't do that please
haha please don't please help
hey I just got one question yeah I do
die dude could never get through hey
dude I have a question for you
I have a question will you release
that's how we should that's how we
should in the podcast all right guys go
see Bryan Callen this weekend in San
Diego a little small place called white
American comedy club and then February
21st I'm at the vogue theater and
goddamn Vancouver and that's a theatre
you son of a [ __ ] I got a text from
crystally a solid I was gonna be in
Vancouver because that's a theatre he
got I just got you gon tell you go call
Phil [ __ ] you I will fill a spare Cooper
come and see me at the vogue leaders in
21st this week at Thursday Friday
Saturday American comedy club get your
tickets cuz they go fast but I saw that
already and he goes like this still
recovery I guess we'll see Callen uh and
then just announce I'm in Miami oh [ __ ]
no but I'm so John no be what are you
going November 15th I want to power my
weekend bro are [ __ ] I wanna March what
is a lot November 2 bro I wanted to pop
Miami's cherry you're you're getting in
there first that's my [ __ ] house what
Miami's like that's bro that's my house
that's in Miami
uh I perform there like crap but I put
some [ __ ] down they haven't forgotten me
all right Miami's marched into 16 Miami
am here I love it you're gonna love it
morning one show Friday to show Saturday
and then Washington DC DC improv March
28th through the 30th palm back baby
J'Accuse me back a calm for tickets for
Brian and myself get them just a finally
kid we're out